those snaps and that radiation is has
been creating mutants this whole time
her reality resetting powers are going
to reset reality in a way where mutants
will now be amongst us the immunes
already exists it's being covered up and
we made it which was not a given it's
time for us all in fact to just adapt
and evolve and mutate because we're
talking about mutants in the MCU trying
to do that thing with the beasts I used
to try to think I was if I could will
myself to Anna more if I could be an
Animorph I'm not going down this and
more that again Jake Marco tobias marina
and then Eric if it's about Anna more
we're also going to be predicting the
successes and failures of the 2020
box-office but first it's the most
lingering mystery of the post Disney Fox
acquisition how are they going to
introduce the mutants and maybe even
specifically a little team known as the
x-men into a shared universe in the MCU
we know it's on Kevin Feige s to do list
we've seen it we stole it we lost a lot
of good people trying to get that but
for some time after phase four along
with also he has introduced by the way
the Fantastic Four just don't do any
zones we're gonna create world peace
pitch me though
just sticking on the mutants thing here
how are they gonna do it how are they
gonna introduce the mutants into the MCU
okay I think they're gonna use the House
of M storyline from Marvel Comics but
they're gonna have to invert it
obviously for anyone who knows how some
W how's the just to explain with the
House of M is it's it takes place after
the Avengers disassembled comics where
it centers around Scarlet Witch it's
kind of like her big storyline and
Scarlet Witch in the MCU hasn't really
and her douchey her powers have been
vaguely defined and she's left in kind
of this like broken state at the end of
the endgame where she's lost pretty much
everyone she's loved so were you yep I I
feel her pain so in the comics what
happens House of him opens with like
reality switching on a dime and things
it's so chaotic and the Avengers in the
x-men everyone kind of has a council and
they decide that they have to kill
because she's God's mouth because she's
the one who's causing it she's like
she's having like a nervous breakdown
kind of yeah she's too powerful it's
real quick they stupidly let her her
brother be part of that company
Peter maximov Quicksilver who's like
runs away and he runs to their father
magneto and it's like please help us and
we don't know what happens at that
moment but reality flips and suddenly
we're in a reality called the house of
them in which it's M for Vegas for
Magneto
it's his society where mutants are now
at the top of society it's kind of like
a reverse society and it's not just
mutants any kind of super-powered
individuals so like spider-man he's not
a mutant but he's like also a celebrity
in this society and one by one
Wolverine kind of has to go through and
like reawakened everyone who remind them
that this reality is false and then it
ends with like a big fight as all these
things do and then in this fight
Scarlet Witch who has two kids in this
reality in this reality her kids die
again and it's part of what was going on
before as she kept trying to fabricate
these kids
it ends with her saying no more mutants
and then reality resets again and then
we restore reality and it's fixed this
way where all the mutants are gone
with the exception of like a thousand
that we care about but the whole idea is
that like the this reality is now reset
with mutants in like thousands and
potentially millions of people who did
have mean abilities no longer have them
so it's like this huge deal I think a
reverse is gonna happen because we know
Wan Division is coming out and we don't
know too much about the plot but it
seems kind of bonkers like it's taking
place in that what seems like a dream
world
old-school marries highly more sitcom
reality yeah that's kind of the
borrowing the vision comics series where
it's like the nuclear family atomic
family so we're gonna see that but that
reality is gonna be a false one and
scared
it's gonna be about scarlet witch's
mental breakdown as she is trying to
decide what kind of reality we need and
she as a mutant even though we haven't
used the M word before
now that Disney owns Fox they can now
say the M word she's going to basically
in her mental state wish for more people
to complete her family so she's gonna
put a comma in it
no no more so that's how wan divisions
gonna end maybe setting up dr. train to
the multiverse of madness and reality's
gonna be switching around like crazy at
that stage in phase four and on the
other side of it we're gonna have a
reality we're mutants exist Wanda
Maximoff is the grandmama of yes her
reality resetting powers are going to
reset reality in a way we're mutants
will now be amongst us follow-up are
they now mutants from here forward or
does she like shadow reality we're
mutants have existed ie did is magneto a
Holocaust survivor still yeah I think
they're gonna do that I don't think
they're going to rewrite or retcon too
many of their Baxter's because they're
too interesting it's too like him being
a survivor of Auschwitz is such an
important part of his character in the
same way that each of the x-men and the
mutant characters have like specific
backstories and I don't think we'll want
to change too much but yeah we're gonna
be in a reality where they have just
always existed and they've always had
they had part of that history so it's
not like they're gonna have to rewrite
the history that we're just gonna be in
a reality now where it's like they were
there the whole time like Disney always
had the rights to the that's not it's
not that like Scott Summers just wakes
up the day after she says that and now
he's Cyclops here who's always cycle
yeah he could always shoot lasers out of
his eyes but just we'd never saw him we
were watching that yeah and it's gonna
be from her point of view so it's not
like we're ever gonna see him before
that he's just gonna show up like with
an optic blast and you were always here
that's a silver road alright
is a great storyline to bring Scarlet
Witch to the forefront yeah and it has
reality altering effects on it and it
could address why these we didn't know
who these people were but they have the
same backstories but I have one question
for you you can lose that so question
okay because it all kind of hinges on
this what is the simple desire that
Scarlet Witch has in this moment that
makes her say let's make mutants you
just simply put what is she trying to do
why does she say that
well I like to think that she just wants
some friends or she wants a family but
to keep this I'll give you another
option what if she it's comes from out
of place if she wants to better protect
earth and she believes we need other
super-powered individuals other than our
you know our Iron Man's or our Black
Panthers or dr. Strange's yeah let's
have like super let's have superhumans
one out of every ten people the army
she'll also be creating she's a
dumb-dumb inherently good but maybe she
thinks at the end of the day whether
you're on the mutant Brotherhood or the
x-men if an external threat comes to
attack whether it's from another
dimension or whether it's from Thanos
you're gonna want to protect your turf
although Mordo wasn't there in that
final battle where the hell was he
Oh son of a [ __ ] he's as strongly hated
Mordo as much as he's loved Anna more
Erik you keep that silver alright that
okay thank you for finally pronounce it
properly so I think like just thinking
more like what we already know about the
MCU right a we know about Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver who are traditionally
mutants they haven't called him that in
the MCU but like how did they get their
powers well is they used one of the mine
stone they use the mind stone kind of
like experimentation shadowy government
organization right it was Hydra right so
I think they're actually gonna keep that
trend going and it's gonna be not
necessarily always government
experimentation but it is a government
cover-up
government asked agencies like your
shield your Hydra and your other groups
we haven't even met yet yeah the five
rings whatever right ten rings uh
[Laughter]
criminal organization but like I think
the immunes already exist it's being
covered up maybe they're being held in
like in in secret facility is maybe they
you know somehow they're hiding their
existence maybe not all of them exist
yet but they're out there they're more
like Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver and
like that Weapon X program like the
weapons are all in Canada that actually
might be the real white we don't care
about them in America yes the Canadian
government is actually the most shadowy
organization of them well and there's
that theory that's what project Exodus
was was this government cover-up of like
mutants that exist among us and you've
done videos about price yeah this is
this little kind of Easter Egg they keep
dropping into multiple films they just
mention it they never really explain
what it is right and so and maybe we
don't know maybe it's it's some kind of
you know US government working with the
shield working with maybe more nefarious
groups something like that because I
think it's it's gonna be hard to explain
how so many of these characters come out
of nowhere
and we also we don't want to start like
Muppet Babies style with like a
four-year-old rogue and a two-year-old
Cyclops
but like this is a nice way to at least
give us a batch of them right like you
could have like a secret you know
facility and like oh look it's storm and
Nightcrawler in clauses in like all our
favorites they're already here we can
dump them on us real quick they're all
babies Sacha's bad okay so it's it's the
government has been doing it and I'm
gonna guess well or I'll ask how many
mutants are you imagine you come out of
this well III think smartly like
Marvel's always done a great job I'm
never giving us more than a couple new
characters in anything right like in in
most of the films we get like you know
Oh black widows in this iron man movie
and like one or two new villains and
that's it we're not gonna rush you with
too many it's like I think maybe we get
that kind of that original tiny lineup
of x-men maybe it's cool one yeah like
the furless beast and the the feathered
angel in all of that right and they just
give us like a couple that's your
wrestling name right angel
you get one traditional yeah no but I do
like I actually think that it is very
likely that some characters are going to
have some sort of tie to the way that
they already brought the two quasi
mutants that they have it just doesn't
address how they'll bring in a whole
bunch everybody has a secret mutant in
there in a cage somewhere but they could
marina is that you're in a basement um
no mine is different mine has to do with
science Oh science so so mine is that
remember when rocket is talking about
how they're how they find Thanos on the
other planet his retirement home planet
and he says when he snapped the stones
to destroy them it a big radiation wave
like gamma radiation yeah gamma
radiation specifically which is
important for science radiated and went
out across the galaxy it was like the
biggest you know wave since the other
since the other snap right and so but
that's a quiz on another planet now
there are three other snaps and they all
took place on earth that's a lot big do
something big that's like if you ever
wonder what if my the window breaks on
my microwave I'm gonna keep making my
food yeah I can't not do it I'm also not
gonna buy any wrap microwave I'm just
gonna microwave this burrito and see
what happens
wrap it in foil foil but that's a lot of
gamma radiation right and it's taking
place with over the course of time so I
think that those snaps and that radiates
is has been creating mutants this whole
time okay and so we just didn't know
that they were already there but they've
been created and they've they're just
kind of discovering their own stuff and
I think and also I think what the first
snap like gave people minimal powers and
then the second snap gave people like
powers yeah and it's like exponential
whatever Ross trying to get a tan on
friends just keeps getting sprayed
that's right he got sprayed four times
so by the time by the time they're
discoverable B it's because their powers
have grown so much that they're not Ryu
can't really hide them anymore like it's
like this guy beast is blue so Rina the
gamma radiation tine got you Rogie
though the moment you walked in the door
growing but here's the question are you
saying then that there were no mutants
before the events of infinity war and
thus there is no backstory for any of
these characters before infinity war as
mutants I am saying it nice because I'm
going opposite like this is what did it
no one was a mutant before that now they
have their powers and they're
exponentially grown so all backstories
are new which gives them a clean slate
story Alton yeah and you can hit some of
the same themes that the mutants were
barring off the the civil rights
movement in the sixties well that's one
it could be off of you know immigrant
but it's fine rewrite Magneto's
backstory so you got a Holocaust
survivor what is he hmm a refugee
stonewall issue he could be that was the
big gay rights movement kicked off in
like the 60s right yeah something like
that right where you hadn't kind of a
similar repression that should be
hardened what mark should be hard enough
for the lady who threw the brick Marcia
Harden was the prosecutor in the other
James Harden but it would be it would be
great if magneto were actually there's a
trans black woman who was the lady who
threw the brick to start Stonewall and
it would be great if that's magneto like
what about say like she threw the brick
at magneto heard that also so these four
events Cosme ins are there gonna be
future mutants if there's no future
snaps o on other planets that were
closer to the planet that Fano snapped
on right because these were all on earth
I mean like that's a lot but they're too
far away from other plan also you don't
have to they don't have to have
necessarily been there for the snap one
you could imagine back to just like is a
woman pregnant right now and if she is
heating up a breed on our microwave
babies coming out wrong but also or
double right every every man every woman
their gonads are very susceptible to the
changes of this might be always why you
don't reliefs yeah alright that's why I
don't so they are forever I mean
essentially you kick-started evolution
mutation it's just reproduction every
time something reproduces it does mutate
literally every single time and that's
real son that's the entirety of science
just mutations over millennia yes yeah
well great way to put it Eric and from
your voice I believe it to be true guys
give it back to me the tweet mutants
will join Marvel phase four from a house
of M where Scarlet Witch says mmm
give me mutants please I need friendship
mutants they've always been here
they've just been shielded
and you almost are directly ripping off
the inhuman storyline on agents of
shield snap radiation causes mutants
times 3 plus everyone's go nuts are
green I'm gonna give you a little bonus
oh yeah and it's real Zach where you
going so you can go do that why don't we
go take a break too thanks um hey guys
I'm back in the blue dungeon to thank
the sponsor this video bang energy every
can of bang is 16 ounces baby that's
right no wimpy 12 ounce cans here it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has zero calories yet it
tastes great with 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is this blue razz
the residents were red berry it turns
out well there are mornings when I was
up the night before writing like a full
movie breakdown that's like 80 minutes
long and I'm just crawling on the floor
but a can of bang energy helps pick me
up see nothing but blue screen it can be
two hours time a blue screen video check
it out bang on Instagram you can get 25%
off your order at bang - energy calm
when you use the code new rocks there's
25 there you can get a variety 12-pack
with a dozen of their flavors slavers
like pina colada cotton candy rainbow
unicorns what is a rainbow unicorn you
ask I don't know but I'm sure it tastes
great thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video and get 25% off at
bang energy com using the code new rock
stars 25 and follow the inventor of bang
on instagram at bang energy CEO
guys it's the beginning of a new year
and we have a lot of movies look forward
to its 2020 if the year we've all been
waiting for for futuristic movies but
this was also after 2019 where there are
a bunch of movies that surprisingly let
us down you love terminator darkness I
love but a bump not in my heart Tommy
bombed
so now we're trying to get ahead of this
feeling a little bit of like you know
let's lower our expectations a little
bit or raise them for some other movies
so pitch me on what you think will be
the surprise nerd hit of 2020 and the
surprise nerd failure of 2020 and let's
keep it to movies and not personal
insults I think the surprise nerd hit is
going to be ghostbusters the jason
reitman film coming out this summer
there's when this was announced it was
kind of controversial because like
people were wondering well is the
pretending like the 2016 all-female one
didn't count something we're like great
yeah pretend like they didn't care cuz
they didn't like it but other people are
like wolves is problematic in other ways
yeah so there's just like a lot of like
negative buzz around it I think this
movie's gonna be great I think it's
gonna be like nerds are gonna celebrate
this film I think people gonna be like
oh this doesn't whatever associations I
have what the ghost is franchise I'm
detached from it's gonna have like a
stranger things feel to it cuz I believe
in wolf hard it's gonna be in is
everything yeah I think it's in I think
Jason Reitman is a fine filmmaker I
think it's gonna be what stranger things
was and take us by surprise
I believe he wrote and directed up in
the air and thank you for smoking and he
directed Juno or was directed you know
from Cody's script right so great films
actually I mean just like a good job
with like smaller stories and it seems
like this is gonna be a smaller story
Ghostbusters it's about like a small
town family like it could have yeah like
a very stranger things giant yeah I
think there are some of these they're
gonna be hits a I think Black Widow is
gonna be in there there's no surprise
there what's our failure okay
speaking of marvel I think eternals is
going to be Marvel's first Bond I think
the cast is too large I think the story
is too big in scope and I think just the
property of the Eternals I'm just not
excited about now I've been proven wrong
guardians yeah right guardians is a good
example I went into I didn't read the
guardians comics until James Gunn moved
that made that movie it allowed me it
charmed me it's one of my favorite
Marvel films
I'm hoping that could be that but
guardians was a pretty simple small
ensemble film yeah maybe Eternals but
when like Feige brought out star after
star after star at comic-con and at d23
it was like I just don't get a sense of
what this story is I'm not excited by
just seeing a bunch of actors like yeah
it's also like a dense backstory yeah
like guardians is like oh we don't know
these characters necessarily not like we
would a Spider Man or an x-man or
something like that but like oh we get
it it's putting a gang of ragtag
criminals Dirty Dozen Dirty Dozen right
Wild Bunch all these stories whereas
this is like a bunch of gods yeah and I
think the maybe some people out there
love the Eternals comics really they
were created as like Marvel's version of
the new gods at DC and the new gods of
DC are actually fairly interesting
thematic stories and was really just
like so Marvel could have their version
of that but you could say that for a lot
of both those companies have done that
yeah yeah but it's just I don't know I'm
not excited about the comic lore now
granted a year from now we may be
sitting in what we got wrong and I'm
like okay I remember when I said eternal
he's gonna suck my head but I also say
what will be the biggest surprise bomb
because I think people check it tomorrow
you can guarantee a certain global
standard I think I will be surprised if
it bombs yeah do we have a creative team
behind it oh yeah Chloe Hsiao is
directing they have two screenwriters
it's and Kevin Feige 'he's touching it
so it's gonna be good and it's his
classic idea of going to people who
haven't proven this doesn't something
giant before but that but it probably is
gonna pay off every single time right
yeah you know Josh Trank is an example
in Man Marvel because of their success
where they put themselves in a tough
position yeah the movie doesn't make a
billion dollar it's like that used to be
like maybe one movie a decade would come
close to that and now they're trying to
put out two movies a year and all of
them have to like that's a lot yes beast
wait so wait till I get shirtless later
don't know the truth behind that I think
the secret hit or the movie that's gonna
exceed our expectations and this is
because our expectations are low
venom to venom you know which was
considered kind of a commercial success
it's surprising how well it worldwide
worldwide a national and like you know I
think most people here or not like
passionate about it but like that was at
best they're like yeah that was fine
it's actually pretty kind it's actually
a pretty bad movie I think there's a lot
of things that don't work in that movie
but I think like I think they're gonna
figure it out
well I think Tom Hardy works yes yeah I
think he works on most things also he
does and there are elements definitely
that I think they got right I actually
didn't hate that movie I think it has
one of the worst time jump plot holes
I've ever seen we did a whole video
about it but yeah and and I think like
the things that didn't work about that
are like relatively easy to fix and I
think Kevin Feige 's continued
investment kind of or connection to the
spider universe is gonna help I think
like even just a little bit of oversight
from him can correct some of the issues
like a look some of it was just like
some character stuff some dialogue stuff
some of the CGI like that's producer
stuff right like we know Tom Hardy's a
great actor yeah
venom storylines are good story lines
see you know what one of the issues was
though was the attempt at humor and it
kind of felt really weird when you're
this cannibal character and he seems
like his threat is very visceral and
intense and yet he kind of is also
making jokes and making fun of him but
honestly you know thor ragnarok was a
complete rewrite of a character that
made him very loved people love the Thor
character now yeah they didn't after two
movies and I think I think we're gonna
do the opposite of what they're doing
with Thor I think then I'm twos gonna be
much darker really and I'm one now does
that mean that you think it's not gonna
share a universe with spider-man I think
it can but like because I think I mean
we assume carnage is gonna be the bad
guy carnage is a super dark like a mass
murderer character right and I think
like frankly Tom Hardy's a really good
actor I don't know if he's good at
comedy but we know he's good at drama
right all the Nolan movies he's done and
everything and like I think let him be
darker right like let this like I know
that'll cost them some popularity
amongst kids and stuff like that but I
think
that's what that character needs you
know it needs to be noticeably darker
than spider-man movies okay that's
that's a big surprise if they do that
yeah so what are you gonna do if you get
it wrong I will I will eat Eric's head
I'm gonna fail I think the movie that's
gonna not meet our expectations and like
this is still a little ways out I don't
think a lot of buzz is built around this
movie but some people are really looking
forward to the Dune other people this
property that for 40 years now it feels
like people have been waiting for it to
be nailed I just don't have any faith
well in in like you know Denis
Villanueva I can never pronounce Italy
little news yeah I'm not good at
pronouncing any name but especially his
like he did the Blade Runner
20:49 he's amazing great work people did
not show up you know he's a good
director but like man this is a tall
task it was like people said you could
never make a movie about Lord of the
Rings and like Peter Jackson surprised
this made it I don't know if we can make
a good movie about doing I have a place
in my heart for this oh me too
David Lynch Stewart but like you know
doesn't stand up as cinema it was kind
of famously a bomb then too and I think
it's like there's something about like
desert planets it's like John Carter
from our I don't know or something yeah
there's something about that I I want it
to succeed but I don't think dooms gonna
be yeah I don't even honestly want to
spend much of the episode onyx I don't
want it
feels like an insult you and it is not
thank you thank you I am soaked so
genuinely excited for birds of prey I
think it's gonna be great yeah I think
it's going to crush the box-office
because it has help from Joker not
necessarily Suicide Squad was a
commercial success everyone went to go
see it personally it was trash but
personal trash trash commercial success
but I don't think people are like oh
Suicide Squad was amazing I'm gonna go
see birds of prey but Joker is in the
same universe and people are just kind
of going like oh I don't care like in my
head now walking Phoenix is the Joker
and birds of prey is like that like
they're just go like that and we just
pretend that the other Joker like didn't
happen and nobody wrote damaged across
their head and it's gonna be great it's
gonna be fun it looks colorful and like
this is the metaphor I'm gonna come with
me here there is a metaphor that I'm
gonna use and it's gonna be weird
strip clubs for men are depressing and
weird and uncomfortable but have you
ever been to a strip club for women they
are fun they are a great time
everybody's having a party Mike
they have literal costumes and it's so
great and fun and this is kind of the
same thing where it's like oh we tried
to do like Suicide Squad was like strip
club for men it's like oh well we tried
we know what it's supposed to be but
like it didn't turn out that great and
we're all just gonna kind of pretend and
but we did spend a lot of money on it
right let's go upstairs to this duel
Club we're up top it's a strip club for
women and it's bright and it's colorful
it's gonna be super fun and it's all
focused on female energy and I'm Lynn
wah I'm just so ready to see it that's
gonna be great man public imagination
we're on a journey there's our best
I like when you say strip clubs for
women as in like women don't work the
other kind of strip club yeah and then
the movie that's gonna take is gonna be
Sonic and it's gonna be so sad but but
it's but it [ __ ] really it shouldn't
because the whole internet made them
change it they're not gonna go see it
they're just gonna be happy that they
changed it and then there may be like
see on they made them change the look of
it but the story still looks pretty
stupid right and that's why people give
movies good word of mouth story catch
the tablet now oh the character looks
accurate to what I remember
okay yeah I'll go but see this that's
not good time no coming back throughout
[Music]
races to defend in the South it's gonna
be very funny when it tanks hurts me so
bad because people cared like especially
that one they were like okay we want to
do right by you guys we're gonna go back
when you spend five million dollars I
don't want the people who worked on the
film to like make less money or be sad
but I still think it's gonna be funny
it's just a studio those checks cleared
alright give them back in a tweet 2020
look out cuz we got a surprise hit from
ghostbusters
are you gonna call Jason Reitman but
Eternals venom more like Wynnum and
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
birds of prey birds of prey takes off to
the to the heavens sonic runs it into
the ground these are gonna be the
variety headline yeah Eric I'm giving
you a road game because to say that a
Marvel movies gonna fail this big -
that's interesting
marina to say that a DC movie is gonna
be a hit it's a big new you a rookie and
Zack I feel bad about how much I wrote
off dune quarter this one's for the
spice
spice life question boom these are not
them these are them guys you guys
haven't seen these but you're going to
now I hear them M night Shyamalan has
three movies coming out over the next
three years
God how what's the biggest twist he
could still pull off maybe the twist
that there is no twist we show straight
forward and he's like that wasn't
actually a twist it was something that
you did not know what's gonna happen and
then surprised you but wasn't it he said
that every time a revelation the most
interesting thing that happened the
movie happens in the last five minutes
of every 95 minutes like a
straightforward Netflix style rom-com
it's just like I gotta find a date to
the prom
you know like just that and there's no
twist
nothing scary nothing on a prom calm
guys who in 2019 did we not give their
their due right who's secretly actually
won 2019 and nobody gave him that credit
hmm that's a good one
do you mean like Oh of all humans yeah I
can be like your aunt I mean she might
win every year for me Marisa Tomei oh
yeah she's like I mean she doesn't get a
lot to do in the spider-man movies but
she's great yeah and like she's great
and also like what's her skincare route
and also like those jeans oh yeah both
of GE NES I really did mean the yeah the
rat from endgame because she wasn't
given enough in that film to end Joker
in yes in Joker
she wasn't given enough to do and she's
amazing and I wanted more but with what
she had she worked well and we're
getting more of her right is she not
she was dominating separately too right
gonna get more and she's still working
you'll get more somebody take a road
well what's a good disorganized Rogge
question what's a good news resolution
for an MCU character so the character
and their resolution that he dev I think
like I'm gonna be for Bucky Winter
Soldier and just like a resolution of
like you know be more externally happy
you know what I mean I don't say smile
because that's a smile it's fine you
he's also like 100 right you hundred
year-old man you could smile smile more
Sebastian Stan with your glowering mug
yeah I think that's his resolution smile
more Peter Parker learn to keep a couple
secrets and stop telling everyone yeah
mums the word it's very practical right
just not telling and also the actor you
know what don't say what happens in the
movies it's the name of the cat who is
goose for goose find a home Oh
goosey cat the cat needs to find a home
and I like to be putting that on him get
yourselves adopted applies to kids to
Erik's made the most sense
so find me on Twitter find me on Twitter
at Marina Mastro's vaguely British Dutch
you should follow at lightning land the
video don't watch all the way to the and
that will be according to my disease
that's a very good impression that's why
I put it done and I'm thanks guys
[Music]